[Applause]
[Music]
give me a minute and I'll show you how
cloud storage can help you store objects
while optimizing the performance of your
apps Google Cloud Storage is a global
secure and scalable object or blob store
for immutable unstructured data such as
images videos and documents when you are
building an app you store objects and
buckets which are associated with a
project you can then upload objects to
the bucket and download objects from it
using the console or gsutil commands by
default data at rest is encrypted and
you have options to secure it with your
own encryption keys you can grant
permission to specific members and teams
or make the objects fully public for
mobile and web applications
when creating buckets you have options
depending on budget availability and
access frequency choose standard
regional or multi regional buckets for
high performance frequent access and
highest availability near lying for once
a month access cold line for less than
once a quarter an archive for data that
you want to put away for years the
objects are automatically versioned and
with object lifecycle management you can
automatically transition the data to
lower cost storage classes when it
reaches a certain age or when you store
a newer version of the file once you
have stored the data accessing it is
easy with a single API call for all the
storage classes cloud storage is optimal
to use for hosting static websites
streaming and storing documents it is
widely used for backups and archives and
it is a great data Lake choice for big
data and m/l next time you are thinking
about storing data take a minute and
look at cloud storage for more info
check out cloud google.com slash storage